this morning we continue our in your
neighborhood series and this morning
we are exploring water street in
historic downtown henderson
that area if you've been there recently
you've known it has seen a lot of growth
despite the ongoing pandemic alex is
live there this morning with more alex
it looks like you're sitting on
something that's
multi-colored what is that all about
good morning
[Laughter]
hi langler it is not edc but it kind of
looks like it
good morning you guys we're at water
street
plaza and i want to get i'll try to get
up this is so cool though so
chad if we could turn to our left here
uh lifeguard arena is right to our left
here from the plaza this is the
refurbished plaza it's
beautiful and if you pan on the left bit
chad you can see that huge screen
on the building they're gonna actually
show nights games
on there at some point and you can come
to the plaza and watch them so it's
really cool it is beautiful down here
lifeguard opened here about six months
ago
as you know it has brought so much new
business new development to this area
it's been great for business
uh one of those new businesses is called
biscuits and bourbon it's a restaurant
just down the street from us here
great great i was gonna say burger place
they do have burgers but they have a lot
of great
barbecue and we got to speak with them
they opened right in the middle of the
pandemic can you imagine how difficult
that was
and they have seen a lot of support from
the community check it out
[Applause]
new business and new development are
taking shape down historic water street
in downtown henderson
one of the newest spots biscuits and
bourbon
morningstar how you doing matthew
coleman is the brain behind the menu
ready to work it's a mashup of barbecue
from different regions of the country
with a twist copied what kansas city
does
what texas does and different areas and
put our desert flare on it there's pork
belly burnt ends smoked wings
and of course there's bourbon they even
do an old fashioned on draft
is it lunchtime yet the plan was to open
this time last year
but that was delayed because of the
pandemic they finally opened their doors
in september
of 2020. opening during a pandemic has
been
chaotic to say the least
the idea to revitalize water street
isn't new
save by scare rebound for elvenas he
scores but got a huge boost with the
addition of lifeguard arena
the lifeguard arena really was the the
lead domino
to really increase activity down here on
water street
the 26 million dollar arena opened in
november of 2020
even with covid restrictions biscuits in
bourbon is already seeing a boost in
business
we found a lot of local support and
appreciation for what we were doing
and we ended up ramping up really
quickly coleman and the group behind the
restaurant were born and raised in
henderson
now they're doing what they love in
their own community being able to come
down here
and bring new business and bring new
life to an area that
needed it for so many years is is
is why does that look so good
so it's great to see them being busy and
get this they're also planning to open
a burger spot just down the street here
in the next few months so that's going
to be really cool too
you know it also helps that restrictions
have been relaxed as you know capacity
back up to 80 percent
and we wanted to get some perspective
about what's going on here on water
street so we spoke with michael conrad
he owns a photography studio here on
water street it's been here about 11
years
he's also grown up here so he's really
seen all of the changes
also became president of the water
street district business association
when he opened his studio so he's been
really invested in growth here
and he is so happy to see the new
additions and people enjoying the area
water street's gone through many changes
i mean it's gone through just a lot of
changes i think this is the best one
to really come down to bring more
families down here i'm excited for it
i'm excited for the things that are
happening
yeah we have heard that from a lot of
people so we're giving you a live look
at the water street district sign
again if you want an instagram spot to
come take a picture this is the coolest
thing we just saw two people
who were running around here at 4am
taking pictures and enjoying all this
stuff so it's a beautiful area
we have a lot more to show you new
development some more new businesses
so don't go anywhere we'll be back live
here coming up at 5 30. back to you guys
very cool bianca our bianca alex i'm
sorry bianca i'm looking at bianca
i've been on water street several times
recently i've played hockey at lifeguard
a couple of times
and i've been so tempted to go into so
many of those places so
now i'm even more tempted thanks alex
we'll have to do a tour yes sure good
stuff